it's very easy in nato to forget that
the south of nato is as important as the
north very often the media focus comes
on
northern atlantic
but you know the south of nato whether
that's romania or the black sea or
bulgaria always central europe is just
as important
it's where we see russia pose a threat
sub-threshold and sometimes directly in
areas like the black sea and often very
aggressively challenge our exercising a
freedom of navigation or indeed freedom
to fly in our own airspaces
and that's why it's really important
that nato's
leadership in delivering a message to
putin that the alliance
is how we are going to stand up to his
bullying and his threats
and i'm grateful for romania's
leadership in standing strong and tall
in the light of a very aggressive
russia at the moment
certainly they are on the front line
they are one of the countries such as
poland and romania who are on the front
line from the potential over spill or
indeed
a more aggressive russia
the fact that romania has sent troops to
poland uh to help in poland
is in a tremendous sign of partnership
and teamwork and it is that partnership
and teamwork that sets us apart from
russia because we ultimately share the
same values of democracy and freedom
rule of law and freedom of the press
something that sometimes
politicians all of all colors and all
countries uh deal with but it is the one
of the most important aspects of our
freedom of democracy a free press
and if you doubt that just go and ask
the people of russia who won't know why
their young soldiers are coming back in
body bags they will be told some
fictitious story
not very far away this morning in a
place called krampus
what appears to be russian missiles
struck
civilian people queuing for trains to
seek a safer place from the war
the striking of civilian critical
infrastructure is a war crime
these were precision missiles aimed
at people
trying to
seek humanitarian shelter
it's not the first time in fact it's
sadly a repeat of many occasions when
the russian state
president putin and his generals
seek to take the war out on civilians
civilian areas and civilian national
infrastructure
but whatever happens in ukraine we must
not let the international community
forget that
what putin is doing today
is building his own cage around himself
that sanctions
and his activities must not be freely
lifted
to allow him to go back to his super
yachts and normality
what we are seeing is a criminal
endeavor
on a free and sovereign country
and britain and romania and other nato
allies will not stand by
and let that happen
i'm delighted to be here today as the
italian typhoon squadron hands over to
the royal air force united kingdom
uh wing we will increase from four to
six the aircraft based here to do
policing the fact i'm standing next to
british and i think italian and
certainly and romanian allies
shows that strength in the air italy the
united states romania and the united
kingdom are playing a strong part in
protecting that domain under a spanish
commander from nato
truly multinational
on the land the united states france
belgium and portugal will be coming here
to assist and support
on the land components
and finally i'll say something about the
united kingdom's role
when all of this is over people will ask
who were there before it happened and
who will be there after
the united kingdom will be here after
the united kingdom was here before in
romania and in ukraine
and from the barrancy to the black sea
the united kingdom will play its part in
contributing to supporting the resolve
and strength of nato
and standing up for all those values in
europe that we share thank you
mr secretary of state i myself was under
the time pressure uh i do apologize for
that so um dear colleagues from from the
media we are now opening the q a session
uh i would kindly ask you to try to
limit to one question and i'll follow up
if possible so the first question goes
to bbc
uh duncan kennedy from the bbc question
for both ministers please um a an
impressive show of force here this
morning but given that
we all understand that russia is
building up its forces again now for
another attack in ukraine do you think
this kind of thing could be seen as a
provocation or do you think that nato
simply has no choice now but to
demonstrate its force
[Music]
how do you provoke a man
who's already
invented excuse after excuse me excuse
to invade a sovereign country and kill
innocent villains you can't provoke him
anymore he is determined
at the cost of
ten you know thousands of russian lives
to
prosecute an invasion of a country that
he has no right to do so
he doesn't care about his own people the
idea is going to care about whether we
fly jets uh in our own airspace not
their response flying into russian
airspace in our airspace that is somehow
provocative is is
i think misleading i think fundamentally
president putin
listens to strength
he listens eventually when the message
and the truth gets through to his people
to his people
and he will listen to the consequences
of what he has done in russia and
ukraine he will listen to the
consequences of his sanctions where is
the russian economy now where is the
ruble now where are his friends if his
friends are belarus and north korea and
venezuela
that's not a party i want to attend
that's not much of a friendship group
worth having
and i think he can't be provoked anymore
he can be deterred and we can help
ukraine
defeat and push back his army from their
aggressive moves
and if he thinks he's got away with it
he only has to look at the casualty
rates of his young men that he sent
unprepared with an arrogance to war in
another country and look at the losses
of his army open source suggests they've
lost two and a half thousand armored
vehicle
he's all in he has put most of his
russian ground forces into ukraine or on
the border of ukraine
and it doesn't look like it's gone very
well so far
yes he will try and regroup yes he will
try and re-equip but so will the
ukrainians with the help of nato allies
and donors they will be re-equipped they
will be resupplied
and the fundamental flaw in the russian
army hasn't gone away
incompetent generals
arrogant generals arrogant planning
assumptions who don't care about the men
they command and not caring about the
menu command let me tell you as a former
soldier always ends up in the bad
results which is what they're getting